mehr als 10.000 menschen wurden
festgenommen mehr als 160 menschen
getötet
die lage in kasachstan bleibt weiterhin
angespannt nach den tagelangen schweren
ausschreitungen wurde gestern nun ein
neuer regierungschef einstimmig vom
parlament ins amt gewählt aber kann das
zur beruhigung der lage beitragen für
journalisten ist es sehr schwierig ins
land zu kommen bild reporter paul
ronzheimer hat es als einer der ganz
wenigen weltweit geschafft und mit ihm
sind wir jetzt live in der hauptstadt
almaty verbunden hallo
hallo thomas paul was macht es so
schwierig nach kasachstan zu kommen und
wie hast du es geschafft
thomas es war in den vergangenen tagen
extrem schwierig internationaler pro
porta hier rein zu kommen in die stadt
al martino das ist nicht nur die
hauptstadt bahn hat die hauptstadt jetzt
ist die hauptstadt nur sollten aber hier
haben die tempelstadt und über 200 tote
tausende verletzte das internet war
abgeschaltet und die regierung hat
gesagt keine ausländer dürften hier ein
vor allem deshalb weil man keine
journalisten sehen wollte wir waren dann
ein besteck an der grenze zu kirgistan
und kasachstan hamster versucht und dann
in einem komplizierten trip 30 stunden
mit dem flugzeug ging nur so kann dann
mit dem zug die reihen und jetzt sind
wir in almaty hinter mir siehst du die
stadt weiter oder man muss sagen die
ehemalige stadtverwaltung komplett
zerstört auch
bürgermeisters hier in der stadt überall
auch immer noch russische truppen zu
sehen die die stadt immer noch schützt
pauli ist die lage aktuell was kannst du
uns berichten
es ist so ein bisschen gespenstische
stille ihr in almaty kann man sagen
zumindest im zentrum wenn man sich den
soldaten er
etwas nervös die wirtin auch immer noch
nervös obwohl die lage insgesamt hier
unter kontrolle scheint die ganz große
frage ist was ist mit den menschen die
in den gefängnissen sind nur wie viele
davon sind friedliche demonstranten denn
man muss sagen die proteste hier die
waren ja nicht sofort gewaltsam sondern
diesem gebiet nicht losgegangen ist ein
aufstand gegen gaspreise einen aufstand
gegen die korrupte elite gegen die
diktatoren hier und dann ist es gewalt
dann bevor was man sich fragt ist was
ist mit diesen menschen ich habe mit
eltern sprechen können die auf ihrer
suche sind nach den nach ihren kindern
die irgendwo in einem gefängnis sitzen
und jetzt nicht wissen wo sie sind was
glauben die menschen vor ort mit denen
du sprechen konnte was hinter der ganzen
gewalt und dem brutalen vorgehen des
regimes steckt
es stellt sich immer mehr heraus dass es
wohl ein kampf zwischen den familien ist
in gewisser form also zwischen dem
jetzigen präsidenten türkei und
nasarbajew den ehemaligen erschafft da
streit gab es angst um machtverlust aber
gleichzeitig und das macht es so
kompliziert gibt es eben diejenigen die
hier auf die straße gegangen sind weil
sie friedlich demonstriert haben und
weil sie versucht haben sozusagen für
ihre rechte auf die straße zu gehen und
das ganze hat sich vermischt da gibt es
verschiedene theorien die einen sagen
dass dann das heft das möglicherweise
hat ausnutzen wollen mit seinen clans
und das ist dann zu großen gewalt kam
die regierung sagt offiziell die
artisten ausländer das angefacht hätten
es wird noch eine ganze weile dauern bis
man weiß wer wirklich dahinter steckt
möglicherweise wird man das auch nie
komplett klären fakt ist aber und das
ist den menschen besteht hier friedlich
auf die straße gegangen sind das auch
über sie berichtet wird denn da gab es
hunderttausende die eben eine
veränderung für das land wollen ganz
kurz zum schluss noch keine prognose wie
geht es weiter
ich glaube total der präsident hat die
lage momentan unter kontrolle aber er
hat eins muss natürlich verloren an
russland wladimir putin hat ein bein
hier im land seine soldaten sind im land
und für ihn ein riesensieg muss man
sagen dass er ihr gerufen wurde paul
ronzheimer live aus almaty einer der
ganz wenigen journalisten die es nach
kasachstan geschafft haben danke für
deinen bericht paul